[MUSIC]
ADRIANA OLMOS:
Welcome to our session
in multimodal interactions.
So I would like to
start introducing
my colleague Jared Strawderman.
He's part of the
conversational design team,
and he's also a lead
product designer
for the Google Assistant.
JARED STRAWDERMAN: And this
is my esteemed colleague
Adriana Olmos.
She is also a product designer
on Google Assistant's user
experience team,
where she is in charge
of the design effort for third
party multimodal experiences.
Before we dive
right in, I wanted
to share a personal
story, a story that I feel
really captures a perfect
real world example
of a multimodal experience.
I was traveling to Asheville,
North Carolina, in October
to attend a wedding
for two of my friends,
and I'm originally
from West Virginia,
so North Carolina is
not that far away,
and I had been to
Asheville one or two times,
but didn't know
the town very well
and didn't have a good
idea where to get dinner.
Luckily, my hotel
had a concierge desk,
and so I talked to the
concierge about what I like,
what I didn't like.
We went back and forth.
He was asking me questions about
how far I was willing to go,
whether I had a car, and after
he talked to me for a while,
he did something
very interesting.
He narrowed it down
to a few restaurants,
and then he handed me over the
menus to those restaurants.
I took a moment to peruse those
menus, looked at the things
that we were looking to
eat, and I made a decision,
and I told the concierge
that we had decided
to go to this southern
restaurant, at which time
he actually resumed the
dialogue between me and him,
and he said, well,
when you want to go?
How many people are going?
And he made the
reservation for me.
So in this mutlimodal
interaction,
the voice part is represented
by the dialogue between me
and the concierge,
and the visual part
is represented by the menus, and
to me, this kind of epitomizes
what a mutlimodal experience
looks like in the wild.
Designing mutlimodal experiences
is an interdisciplinary effort.
My background is
in voice design,
so I've been designing
conversational interfaces
for several years now.
So anything that involves
spoken input and the things
that you hear, that's
my area of expertise.
Adriana comes from a more
traditional visual interaction
design background-- web
sites, mobile applications,
and so forth.
But it takes combining these
two efforts, along with things
like motion design, UX writing,
user research, visual design,
to create a really
cohesive monolithic user
experience from multimodality.
But before we go any further,
let's take a quick step back
and talk about how
we, as human beings,
experience things
in the real world.
ADRIANA OLMOS: So
imagine the last time
you were walking on the beach.
You could literally
hear the ocean,
smell the salinity of
the water and touch it,
and it's all these sensors
triggered at you simultaneously
that makes a
compelling experience.
By contrast, today
our technology
is mapping to mostly three
main senses, sight, hearing,
and touch.
And actually, the way
that we consume content
is basically based
on sight and hearing.
So for the sake of
this talk, we're
going to be focusing
in these two.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:
So in order to have
any chance at all of designing
a compelling mutlimodal
experience, it's an absolute
prerequisite for you
to know what each modality does
well and what it does poorly.
So for example, voice
does some things really,
really extremely
well, and other things
it's just abjectly terrible at.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about those,
and it's really
important for you
to recognize what those
are, so you can leverage
those liabilities and avoid--
leverage the strengths, rather,
and avoid the liabilities.
So let's start with voice.
So voice is very, very good
at flattening a menu structure
and providing direct
access to what you need.
Before I started
using Google Home,
I used to think that
my mobile device was
the epitome of convenience.
It's always right
here in my pocket,
and I have really quick
access to information,
and every facet of my life
is on this beautiful device.
But then, when I
started interacting
with Google Home
across the room,
in kind of a far
field way, I was
able to ask it across the room,
what's the score of the West
Virginia Gonzaga
basketball game,
and it would give me
that score immediately.
Compare that to pulling
the phone out of my pocket,
unlocking it, going
to the sports app,
going to the college basketball
section, looking up the score,
and there's the score.
When you do that with the
far field interaction,
it makes pulling the
phone out of your pocket
seem too inconvenient,
and in many ways,
that's changed the game.
So as compelling and exciting
as the benefits of voice
are, and there are
many, it doesn't
come without it's
drawbacks, and one
of the biggest drawbacks of
using Voice as an interface
is its ephemeral nature.
So users can only retain a
certain amount of content,
a finite amount of content,
in their short-term memories,
and so as designers,
you have to manage
that if they have
any hope of getting
through the interaction at all.
So for those of you who may
have a visual design background,
or for those of you
who have developed
web sites and
mobile applications,
imagine if the only
visual affordance that you
had to present
content to your users
was a scrolling ticker that
goes across the screen,
and the user can only remember
that text that just evaporated
on the edge of the
screen to help them
get through the interaction.
This is what voice designers
grapple with every day,
and this is what we, as
designers, have to manage.
And I'm not even sure
if it had a chance
to cycle all the way
through, but that's
what the ticker said,
so obviously, content--
big chunks of content
are better presented,
and it's a lot easier for users
to absorb, on a static screen
like this.
Let me give a really
quick example.
Let's say I want to ask for the
hours for a restaurant in San
Jose.
I would just ask
Google Assistant,
when is Black Sheep
Brasserie open?
Here's one approach to
answering that question.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Black Sheep Brasserie
is open today from 5:00
to 9:30 PM, and tomorrow
from 5:00 to 10:00 PM,
on Saturday from 5:00 to 10:00
PM, on Sunday from 10:00 AM
to 2:00 PM, and again
from 5:00 to 9:00 PM,
and they're closed on Monday.
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: All right, so
while it's usually a good idea
to anticipate users needs and
over deliver, when you present
so much content that the
user can't grok any of it,
it becomes meaningless.
Here's another approach to that.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Black Sheep Brasserie is open
today from 5:00 to 9:30 PM.
Here are the hours for
the rest of the week.
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So
you give the salient--
the most salient
pieces of information
upfront, i.e. the
hours for today,
and then you defer to the
screen for more dense content
that the user can
peruse at their leisure.
And then finally, one of
the drawbacks of using voice
as an interface is when I
talk to Google Assistant,
people can hear me.
That's kind of how
talking works, right?
So imagine if the next-- the
person next to you, right here,
in the middle of Adriana
about to say something really
profound and amazing decides
to pull out their Pixel phone
and ask Google Assistant what
the score of the Warriors game
was on Tuesday.
That would be really
obnoxious, right?
And of course it is.
But there are some
social taboos associated
with using voice interactions
in a public setting like this,
and even though the
device is capable of it,
it really limits the range and
access of voice interactions
in public settings like this.
By the way, if you're really
interested in this topic,
there's an incredible
session happening
at 3:30 today on stage five
given by Daniel Padgett.
He's going to be talking
about the right use cases.
The right voice interactions
for your application.
I highly recommend it.
ADRIANA OLMOS: By
contrast, visual interfaces
can be as permanent
or complex and dynamic
as we want it to be.
And in fact, in just a
matter of milliseconds,
there's a lot of information
that can be delivered.
Take, for instance, just as
simple as a traffic light,
and we can control
the timing of the red
to green in order to
convey some meaning.
Or it can be as sophisticated
as the YouTube app, where
you can consume content, also
follow up what is happening,
what is trending, and
[INAUDIBLE] what did
you like it or not, that video.
There's a lot of things that
you can do just in one screen.
Now the question
is, how are we going
to be combining voice and
visual information in a way that
is beyond passive consumption,
that is actually for building
interactive experiences?
And one approach is
through conversation.
In a natural conversation
that we have with people,
we point at things,
we describe things,
and this is nice back and
forth among human beings,
and just happen natural.
And the thing is when we start
thinking about applications
and happening on mobile,
there's a lot of information
that we convey right away,
but we have to be careful.
For instance, let's
think of this mobile app
for ordering food.
From here, there's a lot of
things that I can quickly do.
But if you remember the last
time you called or you walked
into the store, you're
actually having a conversation
with the person, and there's
information or just information
that deliver back and forth.
So if you put
these two together,
they look really different.
And in fact, probably
it's more closer
where we're seeing
today with chatbots
and what we're starting to
experience with the assistant.
So one important
piece of information
to take into account
is that not because you
have an app on your phone, that
should be your starting point.
It should be more a
conversation with a human,
where should be inspired
in order to start building
your applications that is
going to live in the Google
Assistant.
The multimodal interaction
is not something new at all,
and in fact, you have
experienced this in the past.
You probably tried
a karaoke machine.
There is sound in
the background,
and then you have the visuals,
and then you're singing along.
So there's a lot of
things happening,
and that's a mutlimodal
experience as well.
We also experience
asking Google questions,
and then Google will present
the search results in a list.
But what we have to
think is how we're
going to be combining these two
modalities in a way that is not
overwhelming to the user.
So Jared and I are very
familiar with the strengths
and weaknesses of these
modalities, voice and visual,
but the problem is, is
that it's easy to fall
into the trap of because
we design for one surface,
we know how to
design it for all.
And in fact, that was the
inspiration of this talk.
It's not that simple, and
there's a lot of factors
that we need to take
into consideration.
So we're going to be
talking about these factors
that we wanted to take
into consideration when
we think of all these
platforms that we're
going to be designing for.
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So we
wanted to talk a little bit
about these factors
that we've identified
to help you think about how
your experiences will manifest
as Google Assistant
comes to more surfaces,
and these factors are,
is your user in motion?
Is the device
designed to be used
as the user is walking,
running, driving,
or some other situation that
makes the screen otherwise
inaccessible?
Think of your phone
as opposed to your TV.
The next is the environment.
Is the device designed to be
used in private, or anywhere?
And is there a
one-to-one relationship
between the user and the
device, like your phone,
or is it designed to be
shared among a group of users,
like a Google Home?
The next is proximity.
So are you close enough to tap--
to quickly tap on the device
to interact with it?
Think of a wearable, as opposed
to something like Google Home
or your TV that's optimized
for far field interactions.
The next is audio capability.
Does your device just
have a very small mic
that can capture speech
from a few feet away,
or does it have an
entire array of mics
that is designed to capture
speech from across the room?
And of course,
visual capability.
Do you have a full ergonomically
compatible 4D keyboard
like a laptop, or is it a
smaller one like on your phone?
Or are you dealing with
something even more primitive,
like a D-pad on a TV remote?
And then finally,
visual output, and that
basically just really
boils down to screen size.
So these are the factors that
we want you to consider and keep
in mind, and we're going to
go through a few of these
on some surfaces where
Google Assistant has already
been deployed and where we
anticipate that it may show up.
So keep in mind
that this is kind
of a future-looking, a
forward-looking presentation
to give you some
guidelines by which
to anticipate how to deploy
your actions on other surfaces.
So let's talk about
Google Home first,
since it was such
prominently presented
in yesterday's keynote, and
it's getting a lot of traction
in the marketplace.
So I mentioned before
about how voice
is really incredible at
flattening the menu structure,
and it's really,
really convenient,
but there's another
upside of speech
that I think is really
important to present
in the context of Google
Home, and it's that speech--
what I'm doing right now,
that is the interface.
You're able to interact
with Google Home in a way
that you've been doing since
you were two years old, by just
speaking to it.
So there aren't any manuals,
there's no tutorials,
there's no learning curve.
All you have to do is know
what kinds of features
Google Assistant
generally supports,
like weather and
sports, and you just
ask for those things the way
you would ask another person.
So if we look at
some of the factors
that I outlined earlier,
if we look about
whether the user is in
motion, they're not, right?
You put your Google Home
on a kitchen counter,
or your nightstand, and
it's usually planted there
for quite a while.
Google Home is deployed in a
private setting, your home,
but it's shared among
a group of users.
So it's somewhat
private, and you
don't have to be close
enough to interact with it.
It's optimized for far
field interactions.
And if we look at
input-output capabilities,
it's got really, really
strong capabilities
for audio, both
input and output,
but very little on
the visual side.
So we've distilled three really
kind of overarching guidelines
for how to design for
actions on Google Home,
and the first one is
don't read, listen.
And what I mean by that
is as you build actions,
and as you develop
experiences on Google Home,
you may be pulling content
from some online source
or something, and a
lot of these sources
are optimized for
written content, right?
They're designed to
be read with the eye,
not the ear, so
you may think-- it
may be tempting to
think that you can just
take these sources, run them
through a text to speech
engine, and voila, you
have your voice interface.
It's not that simple.
Let's take an example.
So in the context of
a weather forecast,
for example, this string of
text makes perfect sense to you,
right?
If I were to translate
this string of text
into something
that's appropriate
for spoken language, I
would say, in Mountain View,
it's sunny with a high
of 77 degrees with winds
out of the north to northwest
at 10 to 15 miles an hour.
But listen to how this--
this is how ridiculous
this is when
you run it through a
text to speech engine.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Sunny.
High 77 F, winds at
NW at 10 to 15 MPH.
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: Totally
incomprehensible, right?
So just-- when you get your data
source and you run it through,
just make sure that it's
appropriate for spoken content.
Don't read.
Just take a few samples,
run them through your text
to speech engine, and
don't look at the text,
listen to it to see if
you can understand it.
The next one is avoid
information overload.
I've already kind of lamented
about the ephemeral nature
of speech, but I think
it bears repeating.
Just be careful how much
content you present to the user.
So if I ask Google
Assistant on Home
what movies are out
right now, or you
want to develop an
experience like this,
this is one approach.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Here's what's playing
at your favorite theater,
"Alien: Covenant", "Diary of
a Wimpy Kid", "The Commune",
"Champion",
"Wakefield", "Guardians
of the Galaxy: Volume
2", "Snatched",
"The Fate of the
Furious", "The Boss Baby",
"Smurfs: the Lost Village",
"Gifted", and "The Circle".
Do any of these sound good?
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So
not only does it over--
does it bombard
you with 12 movies,
it forces you to make
a decision afterward.
So it's kind of a
stressful experience.
Compare that to this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- There are 12 movies playing
at your favorite theater.
Here's what's new
this week, "Alien:
Covenant", "Diary of a Wimpy
Kid", and "The Commune".
Should I tell you about
any of them, or keep going?
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED: So that presents it in
much more manageable chunks
that's easier for
the user to manage.
And then finally,
answer the question.
That sounds like a
pretty vague statement,
so here's what I mean.
If you have
something like a map,
or the user's asking for
directions or navigation,
a map really is efficient
at communicating information
in this really nice compact
rectangular shape, right?
It conveys how far you are
from your destination, what
the preferred route is, what
some alternate routes are,
how-- what traffic looks
like, all that kind of stuff.
So it may be
tempting to just punt
to the screen on
interactions like this.
So when Google Home
was first deployed
and people were
asking for questions
about directions and navigation,
this is how we handled it.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Sorry, I don't have a screen,
so I can't do that for you.
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So pretty
disappointing and unhelpful,
right?
So we learned our lesson.
We thought about why people
are asking Google Home
these questions, and we kind
of distilled a few salient
points about what people
are asking for, right?
In the Bay Area, the
quintessential question
is 280 or 101?
What's traffic look like?
How long is it going to
take me to get there?
So we took this
approach instead.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The best way to get to work
by car is through 87 and 101
North, and will take about
19 minutes in light traffic.
[END PLAYBACK]
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So even
though an image of a map
is much more efficient and can
convey a lot more information
to the user, there's
no reason why
you can't distill the most
salient pieces of information
into a neat little
verbal summary.
Now let's talk
about smart phones.
ADRIANA OLMOS: So mobile
phone is a wonderful machine
that we're using
everywhere in our lives.
And the thing is, there's no one
way in which we use our phones.
The volume would
be up one minute,
and next time it's
going to be down.
Probably you will be
running to a session,
or then you will be playing
with the headphones.
Take, for instance,
this example.
I used to live in Canada, and I
was up there at the ski slopes,
and we knew that there was
going to be a snowstorm,
and we needed to know what
time we needed to get down
from the hills,
because otherwise we
were going to get caught,
and it was at that time
where we wished we could
just ask the phone,
and say, hey, when is the
snowstorm going to start?
And because the last
thing we wanted to do
is take out our mittens when
we were up there, and then
our phone flying down.
So this is a time
where we wanted
to-- we could wish that we could
use our phone as a little home
that we're carrying
in out pocket.
There were other times where
we were running and navigating
through this in
traffic, and you wish
you could speak to
your phone and quickly
get an answer to your
question, but in that example,
the last thing you want to do
is have all this information be
blurted at you, and you just
want to glance at the screen.
So the needs and the
capacities of these devices
are really vast and very broad.
We can be static
in one position,
and then other times
we're running to places.
We use them in a very
private or public context,
and what is wonderful
about them is that we can
have rich interactions to them.
What is even more
compelling as well,
is that there's a lot of
output and input capabilities.
At the keynote we saw
this exciting demo
where we can even use the
cameras as a form of input.
So based on this, we came
up with three guidelines
that we have been observing
while we're drafting
our experiences at Google.
If one word goes away, the
other one should take over.
Let's see another example.
Let's say I'm designing a
third party application called
GeekNum, and what
GeekNum does is tells me
facts about numbers.
It's very simple.
I pull out the phone, and
then GeekNum greets me,
and there's a lot of
cues that it tells me
that GeekNum is there and
enter the conversation.
And also it gives me
suggestions of what I could say,
or I can say my own number.
But here's kind of looks like
if I was not really paying
attention to the screen.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Howdy, this is GeekNum.
I can tell you facts and
trivia about almost any number,
like 42.
What number would
like to know about?
[END PLAYBACK]
ADRIANA OLMOS: So this is what
you heard in their response.
But in fact, if
you pay attention,
it's a little bit
different than what
you see in the chat bubble.
We introduce little
things like this
is GeekNum as a way
to introduce himself
when entering into
the conversation,
because we didn't have
enough visual cues in order
to prompt that.
We also add little suggestions
as part of the dialogue
to prompt the user of what
is what they could say,
and give them
ideas, but we didn't
include that in the
chat bubble in order
not to make it super cumbersome
and visually complex,
because you already have
the suggestion there
below the chat bubble.
So it's very interesting that
we optimize for the strongest
mode, but allow for both.
So let's see another example.
It's basketball
time, and let's think
that Samuel wanted to go at
the beginning of this month
to see the Warriors, and
he can ask Ticketmaster
through the Google
Assistant for the next place
that he could go
and buy tickets for.
And it's very simple and
normal to see a list.
You see that in every
web site, and that's
the way in which we can
consume this type of content,
quickly because in a list
we can quickly scan things.
Then the question
is like, how are we
going to be presenting this
through auditory content?
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- OK, the Golden State Warriors
have a few games coming up.
The next one is against
the Jazz on May 2,
Which one do you
want tickets for?
[END PLAYBACK]
ADRIANA OLMOS: So if you
look at their response,
we say small things
like OK, so in order
to acknowledge that we're
having this conversation
and making it sound
more conversational.
Also, we included
the first play,
that is the next one
with the Jazz team
that is coming on May
2, and this is in order
to give a bit of
information to the user
also through auditory content.
Notice as well, we didn't
list every single game,
because it would
be overwhelming,
and we didn't include
that in the chat bubble.
And what is very interesting
is that this type of approach
lets you consume the content
when you have the two
types of modalities,
but also it's
a [INAUDIBLE]
fallback when the one
is the opposite of the other.
So it's very important
that we leverage
the strengths to be small
and avoid redundancy
across all these modalities.
JARED STRAWDERMAN: So we've
talked about the surfaces
that Google Assistant already
is deployed on, right?
Google Home and Android phones.
But we wanted to talk a
little bit about where
it's going to show up
in just a little bit,
and I want to start by a surface
that was prominently mentioned
in yesterday's keynote, the TV.
So if we quickly look at
some of the conditions
around how the TV
studio is deployed,
it is a static device.
It's literally anchored to
your wall, and it's not moving,
and even though
the user may move,
it's not going to move with it.
It is designed to
be used in kind
of a private setting
among a group of users,
much like Google Home,
and it's too far away
to touch to interact with it.
Now this is the
interesting thing about TV.
Look at where this is
on the output scale
compared to the input scale.
Very, very rich audio and visual
output capabilities, but quite
moderate or limited
input capabilities.
What does that tell us?
That tells us that TV is mainly
a consumption device and not
really an intense
interaction device.
And I think that the reason
that we're bringing this up
is as you anticipate
your actions coming
to life through Google
Assistant on TV, just
know that we have to minimize
it onto a banner on about
the bottom third of the
screen to not disrupt
active programing going on while
the TV is being played, right?
So we don't-- because it's
primarily a consumption device,
people are watching programs,
we want to leverage just that
bottom third real
estate for that.
So know that when your
experiences come to life on TV,
that's how they will manifest.
And because we have a few car
people in the audience today,
I wanted to touch a little bit
on cars and Google Assistant
on cars.
Android Auto is an
existing solution
which does a beautiful job
of moving audio-rich content
by way of projection
from your phone
onto your car's interface.
But let's talk a little bit
about where the car shows up
in our multimodal matrix.
So it is not static, right?
It is moving around.
It's carrying you around
at 80 miles an hour,
so drivers really shouldn't be
looking at the screen a lot.
And even though cars
are out and about
in the public setting, the
cabin, the interior of the car
is ostensibly kind
of a private setting.
And users generally have access
to quick-touch interactions
on their car to adjust
their temperature,
or change a station,
or something like that,
but you don't want the driver
interacting with things a lot.
They should be driving.
In terms of
input-output capability,
cars have these really
robust stereo systems,
so there's nothing wrong
with just presenting
a lot of spoken output, and
they have pretty decent mics,
although sometimes recognition
is a challenge with all
that ambient noise.
But here's what's interesting.
If we overlay Google
Home on top of the car,
they're strikingly
similar in terms of where
they fall on this matrix.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us that Google Home
is a very voice-forward, almost
voice-only device,
and that tells us
that the car probably should
be somewhere in that range
as well.
So a few take-aways as we
kind of summarize here.
If you don't take anything
away from today's talk,
please take this away.
Know the strengths and
weaknesses of voice
as opposed to visuals.
Leverage what speech
does well, leverage
what the screen
does really well,
and avoid the liabilities
that we've talked about.
Optimize for the strongest
mode, but allow both.
If the screen does
something better,
point the user to the
screen, but still let
them do it in voice.
And even though
these interactions
involve both visual
and auditory modes,
they're usually invoked
by a spoken input,
so make sure that the first bit
of content that you're hearing
is appropriate for
spoken language.
And one of the
overarching principles
of using Google
Assistant, and the thing
that we strive
for at Google when
it comes to bringing these
solutions to life for you is we
want them to be efficient.
And each turn in a
conversational dialogue
should be really short and
sweet and easy for the user
to absorb and
consume, and help them
get through their interaction.
ADRIANA OLMOS: So we
talked a lot today
about how to
package our response
and making sure that all these
two modalities cohesively make
a compelling response, and
also that they're there
to serve in case one is absent.
And we also talked about
conversational design,
and how important it is to
get inspired from having
a conversation with
a human before we
jump into diving into the
designing the application.
But the work is not over.
There's a lot at Google
we need to get moving,
and one of them is that once
we have [INAUDIBLE] response,
how does that--
we are going to be presenting
this response automatically--
that is taking into account the
context in which the user is
at, whether they're
running, how we will present
that information, or if
they're just passive,
sitting on a couch.
Also, how is it we
more and more can
do this crossing between
one type of servicing
to another in a manner
that is almost magical,
and the user doesn't
have to ask for it.
And even more
further, now they're
launching our
multimodal interactions
on the phone, how we can make
these interactions like lists
and cars, and all these things
that people can interact
with more dynamic, to allow
for more complex interactions
in a way that is more
reaching and easier to use.
So we're very
excited that you guys
are joining the journey
and start building
your applications with us.
There's going to be a lot
of other talks happening
today and tomorrow.
You're most welcome
to join in case
you're interested in the related
talk for the Google Assistant,
and [INAUDIBLE] as well
that there is a challenge,
and we can't wait to see
all the things that you
will be submitting to it.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC]